you
hi everyone it's Jerry there was a
brilliant game played in round 4 of the
2013 feat a World Cup between gotta calm
ski who was playing the white side
versus Shaq we are Mahmoud er of let's
have a look at it Chomsky opened with e4
Mahmoud er I've played the Sicilian
defense 9 f 3e 6d for the open Sicilian
and after knight c6 and Queen c7 we have
the tamanna of bashed rakov variation f4
this is a common white pawn formation
aimed at combating the small pond centre
of black consisting of D 6 and D 6 it
looks to one day maybe play e5 to take
away a strong defensive piece on the
King side or even f5 to soften up the
black pawn formation and try to get the
e6 pawn to move so that the knight on c3
could hop into d5 d6 still of course the
very early stage in the game a lot of
developing moves and with this last one
since the knight on d4 is defended Queen
f3 is permitted Knight f6 Queen f3 a 6
tops Knight b5 stuff also looks to
expand and inconvenience the knight on
c3 maybe Bishop d3 Bishop e7 both sides
Castle King 2 h1 not a bad idea to get
the King off of this potentially
vulnerable g1 to a7 diagonal there might
be a nicely timed Queen or Bishop check
that could hurt white so it's not so
clear how exactly the position will open
up and so not a bad idea to get the King
to a safer Square this f4 move and King
h1 move they tend to go hand in hand
just as you would see when you Fein kind
of a bishop like g6 Bishop g7 Bishop d7
at first glance doesn't look to do much
beyond connect the rooks and you'll know
from the nature of this position on the
white side in an open Sicilian on the
white side black is the side who has
less space and so will be perfectly all
right with making some exchanges and
these Knights
are not long off from being exchanged
and this bishop will look to take up
residence on this diagonal posting up on
c6 soon enough
so rook on 81 this is the last piece to
get involved for the white side and as
it stands right now there is a lot of
potential energy that has been built up
behind this
pandu oh this a 4 and F 4 duo and these
guys that are behind this pawn duo will
be set into motion soon enough with
either e5 or f5 any of these pawns being
exchanged will free up one or two rooks
one or two bishops so first b5 looks to
kick this night away a3 stops that and
you'll certainly want to think twice
about making this type of move the King
resides on the Queen side if you CAD
queenside castle you're just helping
black to open up the positions so that
they can get right at your King rook a
to be 8 B 4 is on the cards so that
black hood after the exchange of the B
and a pawns looking could look to target
b2 that never comes about though we have
a lot of action taking place a lot of
direct moves occurring from here on out
pouchy first captures on c6 and then
plays queen h3 hitting at h7 directly
the bishop is of course there to hit at
it directly indirectly and it's
important to know that you can't play a
queen h3 right away or in other words
you have to resolve this tension first
because if you play to h3 right away
black captures and then plays e5 the
bishops it and so 2 is the queen so you
resolve that by first capturing on c6
kicking the bishop off of this diagonal
and then play Queen h3 and now what to
do about the pressure against h7 you'll
note that on the right hand side the
clocks I don't know how accurate they
are but they do offer some insight as to
how much time was spent on each of these
moves and the move that was decided on
was rook on F to d8 it took about 8
minutes to come
with that move and what this move allows
white to do is play to e5 and there's
some serious pressure then at age seven
square in fact this 'if I'm advanced
would be netting white some material
however it's not a move that white went
for the move that was decided on was
Bishop to d2 and quite a bit of time was
spent on that about twenty-two minutes
so why wasn't this particular move
played and why was the bishop playing to
d2 instead of let's say c1 where it
seems like it's safer it's unprotected
on d2 and potentially more vulnerable to
the rook we're gonna have a look at
those things because this is a very
critical point in the game a big big
turning point in the game right here you
could go for this advance let's see what
would occur capture capture the Queen
has to take the knight moves crashing
through on h7 and now as white you
certainly don't go for this line it
looks a little bit scary but the King
we're seeing the reason why this rook
moved to d8 and so that with this
variation the King is able to run away
to e7 so we wouldn't have ruck takes on
f6 but we could certainly have Bishop f4
the queen is hit and when she moves the
rook is dead
for example Queen h5 the Queen's come
off white is that material why didn't
calm ski go for this well note the
compensation that black has for being
down the exchange well black has a pond
it's not just the exchange black black
has a pond for it black also has the
bishop pair that adds value and there's
one other detail at least that I'm
saying and it's that this black King
could breathe a little bit easier he's
not going to get checkmated without the
Queen's on the board and so those things
matter and although white still stands
better it's not maybe so easy to convert
this to a win an inch short calm ski is
looking for more but I'm sure this is a
position that he was trying to assess
and he shied away from it he went with
something else he didn't push he five he
played to d2
why not to c1 we're gonna see those
reasons
blacks response first was d5e five looks
to keep the night away he has to post up
on e5 and interfere with the bishop and
Queens communication on h7 94 it is this
Knight is immune from capture capturing
the knight
well it's actually black who is winning
material so not a road to go down if
you're white so if you're not going to
capture the knight what do you do well
you try to engage with the white pieces
you try to open the position up more and
attack this King f5 strikes at E 5 looks
to peel open this F file all these
pieces for white this potential energy
is now again set into motion with these
exchanges and new possibilities are now
present you'll know that with this f5
advance this Bishop could be taken and
in the game it is but I want to point
out first that this move Queen takes e5
can be met in the following way it could
be met with tonight takes Knight pawn
takes Knight and now we're seeing a
difference between the Bishop being on C
1 and D 2 being on D 2 it could now take
up a post on c3 with tempo and this is a
wonderful diagonal once the Queen is
having to move we could have F takes e
there is no time to take the bishop
because of this rip move and this is
dead for black hitting at g7 the bishops
in a pin there's no good solution for
white at this point
black wouldn't be capturing the bishop
but in short we're seeing a difference
we're seeing a very important detail
having the bishop on d2 a very important
variation I should say by having the
bishop on d2 opposed to c1 it allows for
this particular response should white go
in for actually should black go in for
this capture on e5 now if the bishop was
playing to the c1 square at this point
right here how is it different well
after this exchange 90 for f5 Queen
takes pawn
takes Knight pawn takes Knight you don't
have you can't get the bishop on this
diagonal right so maybe you have
something like this but this isn't
leading to a whole lot we're in an end
game that's pretty much equal okay
a deficient pawn on e6 but this is going
to be very difficult to convert to a win
so just uh well very very very important
detail between those particular squares
d2 and c1 and all the more album more
important because once you play the D -
it is more vulnerable and in fact in
this variation that we see after now f5
white is allowing black to capture the
bishop so White's down a full minor
piece let's see how white follows up a
great deal of calculation was made in
this game very very interesting stuff
its F take C converging on f7 opening up
this diagonal black has to do something
about h7 that's the primary threat so
the knight now drops back to e4
interferes with the communication again
on h7 f takes our to me e takes f7 King
to h8 was played if you go to f8 you're
in big trouble fast the Queen smashes
through h7 if something like this you
could take the night you could give a
check you could grab a pawn you're now
looking to promote with discovered check
rook Fe and after one quiet move rook to
d1 how do you defend against Queen to f6
good luck with that
can't do it there wouldn't be a good
solution from that variation and so in
short King to h8 instead and now we have
Knight takes on d5 white in this
position is already down material and is
investing more removing the defender of
efore the main trump for white is this
bishop right here white wants this
bishop to be free to hit at h7 directly
so you remove a defender of the knight
Knight takes on d5 very forcing move
Queen Bishop or hit
the bishop is there to recapture and now
how do you take the knight rook takes
Knight very cool stuff right here we
could have this variation where the
bishop takes the rook Bishop takes
Bishop but now again how do you defend
against this light square assault
against h7 you could do something like
g6 but that's not really a defense this
pawn is pinned white still succeeds in
crashing through on h7 so after rook
takes e4 how do you defend his black
well what was played was g6 one pop-quiz
here is why not play something like
Bishop to g5 where the bishop could
maybe come to h6 to defend against mate
and secure some dark square blockade in
a sense if you'd like to pause the video
see how white should respond okay this
is something you would see in a tactical
book it's a matin - Queen takes pawn
rook h4 double checkmate that would be a
cool finish but black isn't going to
allow that so that's an important threat
to see
so that's g6 that was played and now
over to f4 how to proceed from here well
we have king to g7 and this is probably
the last critical point for black hair
white is able to generate one thread
after another and I think this is maybe
the last chance for black to try to save
this position instead of king to g7 we
could have Queen takes e5 allowing
Bishop takes g6 and the Queen could then
come back to g7 to try to defend this
light square the bishop could then drop
back looking for now rook g4 stuff but
what black could be doing is try to set
up a dark square defense for the king
with h6 meeting rook g4 with Bishop g5
it's important if this position is to
come about if you're on the white side
you have to recognize what is the glue
for black what is holding everything
together well it's this structure right
here and it could be unstuck soon enough
with Queen age 5 and h4 but I don't
believe that there is any
more than a draw coming out of this
particular variation where well it maybe
even just Queen takes here I don't
believe that this game is going to end
decisively looks to be which to be drawn
so that's maybe a way that black could
have proceeded instead of in other words
instead of King to g7 Queen takes on e5
and then dropping back to g7 but we
didn't have that instead it was king -
king to g7 getting out of this pin maybe
allowing for this h5 advance and from
here after East six the threat is to
advance this pawn and then pivot on this
f7 square with Queen h7 mates just
making a nothing move this would be the
main idea to give a check and then
finally give a mate so that's the threat
and how does black defend against that
well of course it's not before it's rook
to f8 not even allowing the pawn to move
not allowing white to pivot on f7 in
other words so what white looks to do
now is simply get on this diagonal this
vulnerable diagonal that's pointing
right towards the black king queen e3
observes two squares d4 and e5 e 5 is
defended by the Queen so black has to
address the threat of Queen d4 because
if the king is in check if the king is
ever in check he has to flee to this h6
square and then that allows rook lifts
maybe directly with rook h4 or timely
rook f3 to h3 stuff so after Queen e3
its Bishop c5 watching over d4 but now
the Queen drops back these retreating
moves are very cool and very easy to
overlook if you're playing the black
side from e1 she still keeps an eye on
one of these of these four dark squares
that she's trying to get to she's
observing a five as well as c3 and so we
have now Bishop to d6 hitting the rook
the rook gets out of the way on h4 and
now there's yet another dark square
Black has to be concerned about this h6
square if there could be a queen getting
there there's going to be big trouble
and soon enough we have that threat
coming about Bishop e7 the rook is hit
but it's ignored Queen III this rook
could be captured well what'll happen if
it is captured let's have a look
Bishop takes the Queen Gibbs check King
here you grab the bishop with the check
you come back here with check and
finally a rook up with the threat of
coming over the only defense is to grab
the rook and this is just going to be
game over very fast for team black so
that's not a road to go down or in other
words it's a good idea not to be
capturing the rook in this position the
threat is Queen h6 also Queen d4 there's
simply not a good solution for black at
this point what is tried is h5 but white
being down still a minor piece is there
to give up some more material after
Queen d4 check King h6 we have the vari
forcing Queen takes h5 there are also
other good moves Queen to g4 with ideas
of crashing through g6 exploiting this
pin but this is good enough a very
forcing move rook takes on h5 and it is
at this point that black resigned
if pawn takes rook we would have rook
check if the bishop captures this is
just made on the spot if King here this
is me and if King here we would have
check him and made on g7 so there's not
really a good solution if the pawn
captures the rook and if the King
captures the rook one quiet move Queen
g7 yet again there's not a good defense
against these light squares g6 is coming
under some fire no good solution at this
point if something like rook AJ we could
have this capture on g6 the king is
running for his life Bishop e2 white is
insisting on getting to one of these
light squares it could only be defended
for so long Bishop g5
Queen here again at this point no good
solution to Queen to g4 mate happening
very soon so as it stood in this game
very wild game very good decisions made
by calm ski that a five moves shying
away from that and seeking more on the
position very interesting tactical
battle a lot of potential energy built
up and we saw it set into motion really
really cool game I enjoyed it and I hope
you did too so it was after this point
after rook takes pawn that black
resigned so that's all for this video as
always I hope you got something out of
it
take care bye